[Music]
what I wanted to do is just talk a
little bit about some of the premises
behind the book that I published with
Imran our armored it's about the what I
think is a baleful effect of what is a
very hegemonic economic idea that I
think has been with us since well for
the last 40 years and this is the idea
which I refer to as market
fundamentalism a market fundamentalism
believes is a theory that you can
actually best distribute all decisions
goods issues fire market forces rather
than using government or other forms of
deliberation and that somehow the
outcome of a market in distributional
terms is by far the fairest and ensures
that people have the most Liberty that
they're going to have and this idea was
first generated and talked about by an
Austrian philosopher and economist
called Frederick Hayek and he wrote a
book in 1943 called the road to serfdom
so the title of this book is a play on
the road to serfdom because my thesis is
that far from avoiding serfdom as Hayek
wanted us to do by using the market to
distribute everything we've actually
created a new serfdom for ourselves by
taking his ideas to the extreme and
privilege in the market in a way a
fundamentalist way and giving it far
more power and giving it far more affect
and influence than it was actually
created to have and so the paradox is
we've ended up where he warned
that we would end up if we were
collective he wrote his book in 1943 at
the height of the effort to win the war
against Hitler in which he noticed that
the British state and the American state
to some extent had used state power and
collectivism to ensure that we had an
economy that worked effectively enough
to fight Hitler and to get a proper
outcome to the war and he felt that that
kind of collective action socialism if
we could use that word would actually
take away all people's liberty and that
they would not be free at all and they
would be dictated to and in fact his
view of democratic socialism and some of
what he worried about actually played
into Churchill's notorious Gestapo
speech in the 1945 election where he
said if the Labour Party won the
election and they'd in evitable II have
to create a kind of Gestapo to run
things and Clement Attlee being the
great leader that he was
put him down with the observation that
actually there were far more things to
worry about than the Labour Party
turning into a Gestapo such as fighting
poverty and ensuring that we dealt with
inequality so after a certain Margaret
Hilda Roberts got to Oxford she picked
up this book and it's fair to say that
it was the most influential book that
she ever read and she was very open
about this when she was Prime Minister
and in fact she was delighted to be
given a leather-bound copy of the Road
to Serfdom by the great man himself when
she was Prime Minister and there's
letters gushing letters between the two
of them talking about how they were
going to destroy the trade unions and
create near Varner and Britain so this
book really looks at what's happened to
our society since that kind of obsession
with market forces has come to the fore
and it's not really a very pretty sight
we've had we've got a very deregulated
labor market increasingly where we have
an hourglass kind of structure so some
people do very well at the lovely end of
the labor market but there's also a
lousy end and the lousy end is growing
and more and more people are falling
into the lousy end of the labor market
and it's particularly difficult for
people now if they're in employment to
earn a reasonable amount of money if
they're not in the lovely end and so you
see people who work very many hours
don't have trade union rights or
recognition so find it very difficult to
access employment rights who actually
are in poverty and 60 percent of those
in poverty now are actually in work so
even though people are doing the right
thing they're not being given a reward
and nor are they being able to set up
and start family lives or develop her
own homes aspire to have children and
all the things that we took for granted
and in fact increasingly what we're
seeing is people who are working longer
hours for Less people's who whose
earnings haven't recovered since the
crash in 2008 and in real terms are
still below who can't see that life is
going to get better for their children
and it was for them and that means that
we've got an increasing level of
pessimism and so some of what I think
we're seeing is the limitations of this
obsession with markets that Frederick
Hayek injected into our system that
Ronald Reagan made certain was injected
into the
American system and that mrs. Thatcher
left us with a legacy of and legacy that
we didn't manage to overturn when we
were last in government where we failed
to change the political terms of trade
enough to turn off this down escalator
into the lousy er ends of the labor
market and what the book really points
out is that these kinds of assumptions
where the price mechanism in a market is
somehow the only measurement of value
where if you're well-off and rich then
you need to be rewarded but if you're
poor you need to be made poorer so you
work harder where somehow morality is
upended so that if you're successful
that is it in itself and somehow and
being selfish at that end is a good
moral thing whereas if you're not then
then somehow there's something wrong
with you because you're not successful
all of these issues are the exact
opposite of the kind of morality and
value system that democratic socialism
would bring to the party and what I say
in the book is that there are five
things that Democratic socialists
believe that we need to reassert so
there are five values really to sum up
what we believe equality in democracy in
Liberty in cooperation not just
individualism not just being isolated
and have in a dog-eat-dog kind of world
but cooperation and internationalism and
I also say that a lot of the issues that
are facing us now are actually only
going to be solved if we cooperate
across borders and if we cooperate
rather than we're in competition so
terrorism for example doesn't know
borders and needs cooperation the
problems associated with climate change
and environmental sustainability
absolutely need cooperation and creating
a fairer more equal society isn't all of
our interests at home as well as it is
abroad and so some of the things I say
that we should be thinking of creating a
much more
all basis for a taxation system getting
away from this idea and this culture
that we have in the banking industry for
example at the moment I'll be gone and
you'll be gone as John Kay calls it you
can extract all the wealth you like you
can do all the dodgy things you like
because by the time they find out about
it I'll be gone and you'll be gone we'll
have taken our bonuses we'll live and
and and so somebody else can clear up
the mess and we don't care that's not
the kind of society that we need to
create that's not the kind of behavior
that we need to reward but we have been
rewarding it and we can't stop it unless
we take a much more collective view
about what's right and what's wrong than
what we want to incentivize I also say
that we need to have a much more
empowering government at the moment we
have had eight years of austerity been
coruscating for areas like the one I
represent up in Wallasey where we've
seen huge problems of poverty huge
issues and problems caused by lack of
access to food because of changes to
benefit systems the rise of food banks
and food poverty is an absolutely
scandal in a country like ours that
actually we need to be take much more
responsibility for the kind of society
we create and the kind of values that it
has for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institutes of Arts and ideas at AI TV
you